dès 2021 à pôle emploi pour avoir accès
aux informations bancaires de ses
allocataires soupçonnés de fraude
un milliard d'euros et c'est le montant
de la fraude sociale en france pour
l'année 2019 selon le dernier rapport de
la cour des comptes selon le même
rapport ce sont plus de 18000 demandeurs
d'emploi qui ont fraudé l'an dernier sur
l'ensemble de l'hexagone pour un montant
de 212 millions d'euros
un constat qui a poussé le gouvernement
à saisir et à inscrire dans le projet de
loi de finances 2010 21 un amendement
octroyant à pôle emploi ce droit de
contrôler 140 agents auditeurs
assermentés de pôle emploi au même titre
que les urssaf et d'autres organismes de
la sécurité sociale pourront ainsi
accéder aux informations jugées
nécessaires pour vérifier en cas de
doute l'authenticité des documents et
des déclarations en vue de l'attribution
des allocations et des prestations
si la lutte contre la fraude sociale
sans être légitime on peut se demander
s'il existe également une volonté est
réelle de s'attaquer systématiquement à
la fraude fiscale dont les conséquences
semblent être plus importantes sur les
finances de l'état la commission des
infractions fiscales fameux verrou de
bercy a examiné en 2019 pas moins de 6
ans 91 dossiers de lots de fraude
fiscale plus de 500 concernent la tva
plus de 17 % concernent le secteur du
btp et les grands groupes et plus de 26
millions d'euros eux concernent l'impôt
sur le revenu des grands dirigeants
d'entreprises
le montant total de la fraude fiscale
selon le syndicat de bercy et solidaire
finances publiques s'élèverait à 100
milliards d'euros en 2019
un chiffre supérieur au montant du
déficit public pour la même année
des montants qui tend à confirmer que la
fraude fiscale coûte bien plus cher au
gouvernement que les faux arrêt maladie
ou encore les arnaques aux allocations
familiales
dénoncé par nicolas sarkozy ou encore
emmanuel macron au final ce constat elle
s l'amère impression que l'entorse à la
loi ne profiterait qu'aux puissants
posant ainsi la question de l'inégalité
devant l'impôt
les charges sociales et la
redistribution des richesses qui mine de
plus en plus
le pacte social en france